So over the past couple of weeks,
some of you have directed me
to this very strange project.
It's a city that's 170 kilometers long,
500 meters tall, and it's basically a line
cutting straight across a desert
with a facade made of mirrors.
And you can travel from one end
to the other end in just 20 minutes.
It's got a ultra
super high speed public transit,
which eliminates
the need for cars and prioritizes walking.
I first I thought it was a metaverse
project, but it is a real project.
The initial estimates for
this project was $500 billion
and now they're estimating at $1 trillion
and it's expected to house 9 million
residents.
There's been a lot of marketing
around this.
So let's unpack this project
a little bit from the design and
urban planning point of view.
So a little bit of context.
Neom is a part of the Saudi government's
bigger initiative
to diversify the economy away from oil.
And as a part of their plan,
they're investing heavily
into infrastructure projects
as well as education,
tourism,
research, age, anti-aging, technology.
And there's a really big focus
on future industries like renewable power.
And the Saudi Arabian government
set up an entire zone
for the Neom development
in an area called Tabuk.
There's areas that's already finished
construction, including a seaside
resort, a massive development
for the royal family, and an airport
directly connecting to Riyadh,
which is the capital of Saudi
Arabia.
The line is probably the most public
and heavily market
a part of this neom developments.
The graphics to date have been
really beautiful and really compelling.
According to Mohammed bin Salman.
This concept has a bunch of advantages
that's going to make this
the city of the future.
By the way,
it's going to have zero carbon emissions
and it's going to run on clean,
renewable energy.
The city is going to be structured
on three different levels.
At ground level,
you're going to have your pedestrian zone.
There's going to be no roads and no cars.
And there's going to be tons of parks
and trees to encourage walking.
The second level functions
as a service level
with shops and other commercial spaces,
and on the third level,
you got your goods and transportation
with this ultra high speed transit system.
This connects the different city modules
so that all of your activities
can be done by public transport
or by walking and all of your daily
needs can be met pretty much
within a five minute walking distance.
This whole idea is built on the premise
that most big cities
are born out of the Industrial Revolution,
and they were built for machines and cars
and industry rather than for people.
The line would save humanity
from this commuting nightmare,
but is a rigid line
really going to meet people's needs?
And is this really the most
conducive shape for a city?
There's just a lot of questions
that come up when I look at this.
The first one was the design's impact
on the natural habitat.
I mean, if the focus really is on
green technology and its design
for sustainability, why does it literally
cut through the surroundings?
You know,
it looks like it's forcing its way
into this irregular terrain
and it doesn't even take advantage
of the coast, which to me
seems like the most natural thing to do.
I studied fragmented landscapes
and wildlife corridors in architecture
school when I was doing my project
in the Korean Demilitarized Zone.
And there's thousands of instances
throughout the world where
natural habitats have been fragmented
from roads or buildings.
It stops animal migration.
It kills off weaker animal species.
It limits genetic diversity.
It creates inbreeding,
which creates genetic disorders.
This is really just to name a few.
And one of the things I humans
can do to help
these situations
is to create these wildlife corridors.
And honestly,
I don't know if this was overlooked
because the project is in the desert,
but even within a desert, there's
thousands of animals and plant species
like lizards, snakes, turtles, sand,
cats, hares, like literally thousands.
And I would assume, especially as you get
closer to the water,
you would have more animal species.
So creating this massive
170 kilometer wall,
it sounds really problematic.
Also, this giant mirror of wall
is going to reflect the light
and it's going to create these two really,
really hot heat zones.
And it's
going to fry everything around it.
Not to mention birds flying into it.
The second thing is transportation.
How does this extremely long line
cut transit time
compare to a rectangle or a circle?
The proposal relies on the super fast
transit system
that's going to take you from
one end to the other in just 20 minutes.
That would mean that
the train runs at 525 kilometers per hour.
If you're not accounting
for all the stops, the fastest train in
the world is the Shanghai Maglev,
which runs at 460 kilometers per hour.
There's also a successful examples
of how transit has been incorporated
into the streetscape at a fraction
of the cost of these bullet trains.
I feel like this design
and this concept of the line is creating
unnecessary issues and trying to solve
that issue with expensive technology.
And I think design should provide
the best organic solution,
and we should use technology
to improve on that.
Also, organic cities, they grow.
You know, how is this line
going to allow for growth?
Do you just keep extending the line
like adding more modules
or do you add perpendicularly, in
which case it wouldn't be a line anymore?
Also, if you look at studies on innovation
throughout history,
like where good ideas come from
by Steven Johnson.
He says by innovation.
Grew exactly when cities started to grow.
And that's because there's
a lot of cross-pollination
and accidental meeting of ideas.
He describes
the different environmental examples
that breed innovation
and every single instance.
It's more of a maze
than a straight forward line.
So even if the city has been programed
so that you can access your grocery store
or your local coffee shop
within a five minute walking distance,
if they're spending
all of this money on it, I'm assuming that
they're going to want innovators
and leaders to come live here.
But a linear, rigid city
just doesn't really seem
like the right kind of environment
for the breeding of ideas.
There's also the pure logistics of this
as well.
For example, let's
say you're making some mac and cheese,
but you realize you don't have any butter
and how can you make any mac and cheese
without any butter?
And so you decide to quickly
go to the grocery store
and if you want to do it
fast, you have to walk, which
with this type of verticality,
you have to take the stairs
if you want to do it quick.
But if you have mobility issues,
you're forced
to take the elevator,
which we all know is a little bit slow.
And as we've seen from the pandemic, it's
the perfect breeding ground for disease.
There's some talk of, again,
another high tech
vertical transportation system,
which I'm sure will help
revolutionize transportation
in a lot of already densities.
But putting these constraints
at the outset of the design
to serve this very rigid concept,
I don't know how sensible that is also.
Do you think we're going to be able
to cycle here?
We all know cycling to your daily commute
increases health, lower
stress and obesity.
But you need roads of some size, which
this design doesn't
really seem to allow for.
So do you need to go to the basement floor
to ride your bike?
I don't know.
I'm also not super sure how much daylight
you're going to be able to get in there.
This gray box is residential,
but if you live all the way over here,
that's a pretty unpleasant situation
for you.
And you're not going to be able
to get a lot of daylight.
So maybe the ones on the lower
level are the servants and the workers.
And up here, that's
where all the millionaires live.
If this gets built,
I'm sure they're going to figure out a way
to properly ventilate
and structurally support this.
But I think it's going to come
at a serious cost.
Every structural engineer
is going to tell you that putting up
a massive slab of wall is going to create
some serious lateral stability issues.
So that means all of this is going to need
to have some beefy structure.
This is the classic thermal convection
diagram.
The desert gets up to 55 degrees Celsius.
That's 130 degrees Fahrenheit.
So if the roof of this thing stays open,
like in the renderings, you're going
to need some serious cooling in there.
Or maybe they're just counting on all of
these areas being shaded most of the time.
But then I'm kind of curious,
how do you get all of this lush greenery?
Right.
These are only the handful
of the many issues with this concept.
I feel like a lot of unnecessary
constraints
have been created
to serve this very simple concept.
It reminds me of like an architecture
student project
that inevitably gets ripped apart
during a grid.
But let's see that they're able to resolve
the issue of daylight, of walkability.
They can make trees
levitate, and sunlight can bend geometry.
But in the end, the question is still
who is going to live here?
You know, what kind of communities
are they going to have?
This is a $1 trillion project
and they're estimating that it's
going to cost even more
because all of these technologies
still have to be developed
and they're really trying
to get the state of art for everything.
The Saudi government is obviously
not going to foot the bill for everything.
You know, that's partially the whole point
of this entire marketing campaign.
It's to attract investors
in typical developments of this size.
They're going to phase it
so that the profits from the first phase
confront the second phase and the second
to the third and so on and so forth.
But that would lead to old and new
sections and with typical master plans.
These sections are designed
very strategically
so that the first phase, you know,
even if it's a standalone,
can be a livable and pleasant community.
But with just a couple
of strips of the line,
which is the old section
and which are the new section,
and cannot even function
as a strip on its own.
The idea of a massive city
is really cool, but
who's going to want to move in there
when it's just one little section?
The Saudi government really
wants to set up Neom as a free trade zone
with its own tax system and legal systems.
That's separate from Saudi Arabia's
super conservative legal system.
And they're really trying to create
an environment for global investors.
So maybe it'll be a trade area
where people come and go,
but maybe few
people will actually live there.
They're also proposing
that AI is going to help us live
more efficiently,
reduce waste and live more comfortably.
But people are already skittish
about giving up their data,
even for the most utility sharing needs.
And so to expect people
to do that for a city that's built
and funded
by an authoritarian government is,
I think, asking for a lot.
I have no doubt that this project is going
to push the boundaries of technology.
They're already making some really,
really interesting advancements
in desalination technology.
But building a city from scratch
instead of solving the existing problems
is, in my opinion,
the antidote assist of sustainability.
Many parts of Saudi Arabia
don't even have a proper sewer system.
The country is already full of failed
or abandoned projects, and I think they
need to be spending this money
on improving the existing infrastructure
and improving the lives of the people
who already live there.
You know, if sustainability
and creating a better future
really is their goal, what's also missing
from their marketing campaigns
is that there's thousands of people
already living in this area.
There's a tribal community
that's been there for centuries,
and Neom is displacing
thousands of tribal members
and I think that brings us
to the whole ethics behind all this.
It is true that Mohammed bin
Salman is making a lot of social
and cultural progress in Saudi Arabia,
especially for women.
Since 2018, women were allowed to drive.
In 2019,
they were allowed to apply for passports,
meaning
they could travel without a male guardian.
And they're also requiring equal pay
for women, for equal work.
And, you know,
before that, women got about
half of what men were getting paid
for the same type of work.
And all of these reforms are a huge step
for women's rights.
But the truth of the matter is,
nobody can criticize the prince
or his policies.
You guys might have heard of the murder
of Jamal Khashoggi, who was a Saudi
Arabian journalist who was critical
of the prince and its policies.
He was actually dismembered
and murdered in Istanbul.
And CIA reports
found that Mohammad bin Salman,
although he denies
it, is the one who ordered the killing.
He's also been responsible
for some serious human rights violations,
including the arrest of a massive number
of political activists
throughout the country
in this project as well.
There's been zero consultation of people
who are going to live there
or who live there already.
And so, I don't know, maybe the purpose
of this whole project
isn't to build a real city.
After all.
Maybe the whole purpose of this project
is to repair the reputation
and promote this positive image
for the prince and his kingdom.
And they're saying to international
investors, look, women can drive now.
You can wear what you want.
We're open for business.
I don't want to get too bogged down
into the politics here,
but I think this is an interesting point
to end the video.
Architecture has been used
throughout history to promote
a political agenda
and the simpler the idea, the better,
especially today with political messaging
being delivered right to our fingertips
as beautiful images
and these grand utopian visions.
It's really hard to distinguish
what's what.
It really makes me wonder
what is our role in this?
I remember taking a course on ethics
in architecture and this architect,
Carl Sappers, he outlined
the ethical obligations of an architect.
The architect has the obligation
to, number one, make sufficient
income to support the architect
and his or her family.
Number two,
he has the responsibility to the
sometimes conflicting requirements
of serving the client.
And number three, to the
sometimes preceding
and competing interest
of serving the public.
And number four, he has the responsibility
to have devotion
to the art of architecture.
The second and third are actually outlined
in the AA
or ABC Code of Ethics,
and not all of these points are equal.
If there is a conflict
between any of these points,
you have to put the client's
interests over your own,
and you have to put the public's interests
over yours or the client's.
What is the architect's responsibility
when they're asked to come up
with a concept like this anyways?
I'll leave you guys with that.
I'm really curious what you think.
So let me know
your thoughts in the comments.
If you like this video,
I think you'll also like the video
where I talk about
architectural concepts in sci fi movies.
I'll leave it right here.
And with that,
I'll see you guys in the next video. Bye.